man my mom had to watch me [ __ ] oh my
God I'm like I'm so sorry for what I do
to women sometimes your mom would stand
up and be like that's my Steve well you
just feel like it just doesn't feel kind
of cool the act of penetration
penetrating a woman it's like are you
doing it in a special way that no it's
just like it's just the idea of like
watching it Go in is like you know man
I'm talking my mom's watching this [ __ ]
I was watching this [ __ ]
[Music]
you guys know who Gavin knew someone's
wife is wasn't she some an actress she's
an actress moments ago I I found out I
thought that was pretty cool
well did you hear about the story what's
the story no I don't know the story so
um she is part of the sexual assault
trial of Harvey Weinstein oh she's was
she me too she's me too and she is
saying that uh there was an incident in
2005 when Harvey Weinstein raped her
and then they very
uh uncomfortable moment during court
um she was asked by Harvey Weinstein's
defense
to recreate how she faked an orgasm
the defense was like it's like well if
if you didn't like it why'd you orgasm
yes whoa what did she orgasm
according to Harvey I guess Harvey
saying she did and she said is that the
point in contention in the [ __ ] like
court case wild what the [ __ ] they're
like show us how you did it then yeah
like what according to Harvey they had
consensual sex right and then she
testified that she made pleasure noises
after she put uh her hand on Harvey's
penis to encourage him to ejaculate but
she's saying that she would felt
pressured and it was like a rape
situation and Harvey's like Yo dude she
was into it how how could someone be
into it like look at him and like she's
beautiful do you think anyone is
actually ever into him into him like
there's that one girl that like actually
liked them for him I actually think so
because because let me um get to how she
described his penis she said it's kind
of fish like the penis huh something was
distorted in the testicles lots of skin
lots of skin down there that's a real
quote that's not a Stephen green
original yeah yeah I don't know dude I
gotta see the [ __ ] no I heard that
his dick is [ __ ] up like it's like
confirmed wow
yeah it's fish-like yeah someone was on
Joe Rogan talking about it like like I
heard like there was a rumor that his
dick is all deformed and like he was
like an actual like his weird like a
he's pretty weird looking she's pretty
deformed he has some extra skin on his
face for sure he's got some extra skin
in general he looks like he has a
medieval disease
like he looks like he works at like an
Iron Forge and he wears like a clothes
he's a blacksmith yeah remember how they
rumored that uh they designed one of the
Orcs from Lord of the Rings after him
yeah yeah and he has a bunch of skin
extra skin on his face yeah well I guess
that's the only way you could get laid
sometimes huh you have to really be like
a super duper producer isn't that crazy
though like this
so she wasn't even like a major actress
and he's also done that to Major
actresses that means no one in between
is safe like everybody across the board
like the whole call sheet I found out
about Harvey years ago before this
happened because my buddy's a producer
in Asia and he was like so Harvey
Weinstein was really known for bringing
in
um films to the states and it wasn't him
but one of his actors she had a meeting
and then for some reason he didn't want
to meet the group that was in charge of
the film he just wanted to meet her so
she's like oh that's weird so then so
then she went up and she came down and
said [ __ ] that guy whoa and then
apparently she was propositioned I
joined with Ryan when I say why didn't
JoJo warn the world
I did people didn't care on do you see
old JK new [ __ ] I've been saying that
[ __ ] since like 2009 I see so you tried
you tried I tried I found out about it
in 200 yeah eight you blew the whistle I
blew it seven or eight I was breaking
news here on JK news but unfortunately
the source is mean yeah that sucks and
no one ever believes me no one asked you
to go to court yeah but that's what Rose
McGowan got the courage from his
initiative yeah him shirtless holding a
tomahawk smashing walls do we know how
many people uh uh accused him of the
metoo thing
um oh man it's a lot it's dozens yeah
like triple figures I mean it's just not
stopping there's just like someone else
all the time yeah is Harvey Weiss he's
he's locked up isn't he he locked up now
or is he still going to court he's going
to court but I think he's he's held like
like OJ style when he was like up for
the murder charges but you know what
they should do they should Reco this
case where
everybody that was involved including
Harvey they should line them all up who
cooperated like there's stories about
assistance and producers and people like
lining up
meetings for meetings knowing that this
guy's a predator and setting him up and
creating a situation where they would
hush it up well doesn't he seem like the
type that would rat all the all those
people out for a better deal maybe let's
get them all done yeah I mean well I
don't know if they're gonna give Harvey
a deal though
you know I mean he's the top of the food
chain on this thing like it's hard to
get he's the main guy yeah that's who
they want true
um but so what's what's awkward is that
um Harvey's defense attorney continued
to grill
Newsome's wife Sybil about why she faked
an orgasm with Harvey Weinstein If he if
she was getting raped at the time
whoa what being a defense attorney is
Wild is is yeah is that is that not
logical I'm gonna fake this so that way
it's over quicker and we can move on and
then I can escape this nightmare yeah oh
like maybe he was like I'm not stopping
until you come
like that because isn't it over after he
Jesus and that's what she says she says
I was making noises to get him to finish
ah he had already raped me this is gross
I'm sorry and she started crying Jesus
bro yeah and then no that's isn't that
enough of an explanation
make her do it dude that sucks did the
judge step in and be like all right
okay so instead of 78 counts it's 77
like what you know what I mean like you
guys want this one
jeez that is crazy it's the judge like
the woman will answer the question
the woman
please continue
I can't that's like this crazy shit's
happening chords man yeah they just talk
about [ __ ] I was telling you guys about
my friend who uh got accused of
um basically this girl that he had sex
with in high school said that she wasn't
willing to do it so uh took him to court
but because she cheated on her boyfriend
she wanted to like save her reputation
so she said that he forced her and so
had to he didn't know what he was well
no one knew what he was going to do they
were like dude how are you gonna even
prove that that you're innocent and he
goes well uh I secretly recorded it
yeah he secretly I'm surprised they were
able to use that as evidence right
because I'm so glad he's so weird I know
can you imagine if he wasn't that weird
so it changed the violation but because
of that what they had to do is the court
had to watch the whole thing
to make sure that at no point she said
no
so his family had to see it and to make
sure that his family saying is probably
different but her family seen a wild bro
dang yeah but that's like you wouldn't
think Court would do that well and it's
so awkward to be like okay we're about
to watch a video
let's listen for notes and I didn't know
I don't know if it was like I wonder if
someone's throwing their voice in the
court
but like oh my God that was really good
what the [ __ ] gotta believe that what
the funny thing I don't know if it was
like in court the way that you
visualized Court looking it might have
been like in a different type of setting
where they go to a room look at the
roller team but he said that that's like
his main story about how he almost like
ruined his whole entire life that's
[ __ ] wild that's a heavy That's Heavy
that's man my mom had to watch me [ __ ]
oh my God I'm so sorry for what I do to
women sometimes your mom would stand up
and be like that's my Steve well you
just feel like it doesn't feel kind of
cool the act of penetration penetrating
a woman it's like doesn't it feel kind
of like [ __ ] up in a way especially in
the context of a courtroom yeah are you
doing it in a special way then no it's
just like it's just the idea of like
watching it Go in is like you know man
I'm [ __ ] my mom's watching this [ __ ]
I was watching this [ __ ] but I think
it's your perspective man the way you
got to look at it is the big hug yeah
it's a massive receiving hug with a
bunch of thrust I mean you're kind of
the one getting hugged yeah yeah we're
getting hung yeah we're putting in to
get hugged yeah we're putting it
together both parties are happy about it
but like that I'm sandbox my mom's
watching them yeah that's hard to speak
into that yeah but she made you that way
because that's when all the Catholic
guilt comes crashing comes Crashing Down
if anybody should have [ __ ] more than
you it was probably your parents so they
watching it is like oh look our
Creations making more
[Laughter]
perspective he's pretty good he's a lot
better than I thought yeah they're just
playing Sims your mom's just like I
gotta teach him a thing or two oh [ __ ]
hey dude
milkworm
do you really think that it's like
that's a kind of a funny question do you
think there's anything that your mom
could kind of teach you about that don't
don't make it too real hey save it for
OTR hello bro you know what my favorite
thing
you save it for a 20 minute combo oh God
it's dive deeper into this like I know
dads can they're always bragging about
that [ __ ] but like moms that's kind of
weird I like making my mom queasy about
sexual [ __ ] it's her reaction's so
[ __ ] funny I bet dude what kind of
stuff do you say well she watches like
all of our videos right and then what
all of them all of them she knows that
you [ __ ] ate out a hooker she's TR
dude she knows everything
and then I'll get these phone calls and
she'll be like hey uh can you not talk
about [ __ ] so much like I'm sure you
have kids watching and I'm all like well
they gotta learn somehow right you're
like Mom that's my entire [ __ ] brand
yeah
it's my theme I built the Empire on this
and then the other we're all having
dinner she was she was talking about
like Gainey weight in Hawaii because she
eats so much and then Hannah was like
yeah me too I'm gaining weight and she
goes yeah she goes like
um what are you feeding her and I'm like
I'm making sure her titties and ass are
growing
loves it
not sex jokes but body part jokes like
peeing and everything like it's not
there's not there's no shame in that but
then the sex jokes is a new thing that I
like doing good dude out of all the
stuff that your mom watches [ __ ] is
like her thing and she's like oh please
there's way more stuff than that I feel
like we say some wild [ __ ] I think it's
because she recently translated it and
she understood what it is she doesn't
yet know about all the other stuff yet
maybe there's no Japanese translations
yet what about all the rim job stuff you
talking about maybe
Grizzy Grizzy greasy
I was with the chick and
um it was kind of cool because her
parents were more open sexually like
they were they were openly talked about
sex more but then her mom one time was
talking to all of us about how blow jobs
were disrespectful and I was like
disrespectful oh lame why is it what was
our key Point she just thought it was
[ __ ] weird that women would like get
down their knees and put your penis in
there did you feel bad for her dad yeah
that's exactly what I did I instantly
just looked at this guy
I honestly did I was like because he
just has to sit there and like yeah you
know so disrespectful such a good point
such a good [ __ ] point you know so he
wasn't America supporting it he was just
like he was tacitly like you know uh
just sipping coffee in the back
just hoping that we got through the
conversation quickly you know is it
looking at the ceiling for some reason I
was just a poor son of a [ __ ] I guess
if you don't know what you're missing I
was like your dog water is in the blow
jobs my friend
and you know what else I'm just kidding
I'm just kidding what else right get
over there
[Music]
[Music]